the red lightsaber has been synonymous
with the dark side of the force the same
color has been wielded by every major
Sith character from Darth Maul and Darth
Sidious to less official Sith like kylo
Ren for lightsabers to take on a red Hue
and Cannon the kyber crystal inside has
to undergo a process known as bleeding
in which an individual pours all their
negative emotions and feelings into the
crystal however there are instances
throughout the Legends timeline where
Jedi are seen wielding red lightsabers
even Luke Skywalker briefly wields a red
lightsaber in various new and old Star
Wars comics while some of these
instances are no longer considered canon
in the universe they do beg the question
how come there are no naturally
occurring red lightsabers in Canon when
every other color seems prevalent in
Canon sources there are moments where
Jedi use red lightsabers but only
temporarily before fully embracing the
dark side of the force Anakin Skywalker
uses a red lightsaber to execute Count
Dooku and Obi-Wan Kenobi briefly wields
one in Star Wars the Clone Wars during a
fight against Darth Maul in other
instances characters who defect from the
Dark Side like asajj Ventress keep their
red lightsabers